[Applause]
right good afternoon lady we're start at
a second early briefly the very urgent
prioritized emergency evacuation
announcement should we require to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest exit
which is behind Simon
there is one fire exit in the room if
you need to evacuate the room do so by
the glass door external fire exit
straight first step staircase
please hold both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs but they please
allow others to exit before they go down
the fire escape where you can be given
assistance our assembly points of public
car park beside the Civic suite please
do not delay your evacuation to collect
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by council staff please note that this
meeting is audio recorded and can you
please room remind you to switch off
your mobile phones or turn them to
silent on that point chairman Bob why we
are and we've got to speak up loudly
because we've had communications issues
again and I understand so but it is
being recorded so please speak up as
clearly as you can apologies for absence
I don't think we've got any non-members
attending yep how's the ward counselor
mrs. Shaw
and the minutes from the meeting held on
the 7th of October 2019
as far as I'm aware I haven't heard
anything I don't think Sonia here so can
we take those as accepted thank you very
much any declarations of interest right
Justin of course he's mentioned in item
5 but I do back onto the bridge okay
thank you very much
right on to item number 5 which is I
think it'll be an out usual format which
I will pass over sit down to highlight
any issues you'll and have every
opportunity to ask any questions or
raise any points at you you wish to and
then we'll go from there
and floor is yours okay Thank You
chairman so this report has been put
together in response to a request made
at the last meeting in Atlanta coercive
subcommittee members requested quarterly
updates through the Subcommittee on
housing delivery so this report has been
put together and it covers effectively
two quarters so from April 2019 to
September 2019 obviously future meetings
of subcommittee will pick up future
quarters including the quarter that has
just ended so members might be aware or
they hopefully are aware that the
council recently published its first has
a delivery test action plan so the
housing delivery test is something that
has been introduced for changes to
national policy and it basically
assesses each local authority's
performance over the previous three
years
so it's s is the number of homes that
have been delivered relative to how many
should have been delivered over that
period and various tiers of under livery
are penalized in various ways one of
which is to produce an action
which which members have previously seen
and agreed so what I would summarize
really is that over the period April
2019 to September 2019 we estimate that
around 106 homes have been completed
which comprises 17 market houses and 36
affordable houses so 106 over
effectively a six-month period
extrapolated would work out at around
two hundred and twelve homes over the
course of a year if it stayed stable
over the remainder of the year which
would be a shortfall against the council
adopted housing target and a relatively
large shortfall against its local
housing need pick up which is basically
how many homes the government thinks we
should be delivering however just until
we do some caveats on lands what I would
say is that there's relatively strong
evidence to suggest that that more than
212 Wellings will be completed over over
the course of the year mainly because a
large number of the strategic sites are
now have now commenced and whereas
previously it was really only the whole
Road in Rockford and Starling brickworks
in Wakering that were delivering houses
at any kind of appreciable scale now we
have had technical starts in West Raley
in whole bridge and you know combined
with continued delivery a Hall Road and
the second Starling site in great weight
so my professional opinion would be that
it's likely that we will see more than
212 dwellings completed yeah but whether
it's still a short
against the 385 local housing need
figure there is some likelihood of that
happening
the only other caveat that I would
provide on on those numbers really is
that interim monitoring so within the
year trying to monitor completions it
can be quite difficult so quite often
there are delays in developers declaring
completions and there are probably about
a hundred and one different ways of
representing completion we often rely on
having them being signed off by Building
Control or private building inspectors
and that is a process that through my
experience I would say often sees delays
for example we we were not aware of many
of the completions on Pancho's nursery
until about six months after they had
been signed off such is the nature of
some of the reporting from the private
building inspectors so there is some
likelihood about 106 that I've just
mentioned there's an underestimation but
it could easily be 120 or 130 homes what
you allowance for that under delivery
and I suppose the only other thing I
would say is you know clearly we have
this housing Delivery test action plan
it has actions in there short-term
medium-term and long-term that are aimed
at obviously trying to improve delivery
over the next you know 5 10 15 years and
my I guess recommendation really is it
there's probably no need to really
deviate from that action plan at the
current time I think it's probably still
an appropriate course of action to take
in response to this delivery but clearly
there is there's a lot of value in
continuing
to monitor delivery over this pier over
future periods through the subcommittee
and if members see fit to take
additional actions or different actions
then that's obviously something that we
have regards to that we we have also
clearly got other sites in the pipeline
that that may become before that the
Development Committee and then in the
next few months Southeast Ashington is
one and you know subject to their
delivery there that's appreciable number
of houses on this site situation so I'm
happy to take any questions you might
have on any of that so is this my cell
first yes a few stage surely the same
what we applied at the end of it is a
difficulty and entertaining pleasures at
the same time and I noticed you might
make sure different ways of signing off
and these are some substantial delays
which obviously has an impact on our
income tax as well so what steps are
being taken to okay so I suppose on the
first point I guess the one reason why
it's slightly easier at the end of year
is that often this is when the private
building inspectors I guess mop up is
probably the best word I can use so they
any you know Maximus during the year is
kind of they normally protect a result
in a year end what that means is that we
quite often get returns from the private
building inspectors at the end of year
which are almost corrections to previous
returns so in that sense we quite often
pick up additional completions at that
stage
I suppose the other point is that at the
end of the year when we're working on
the authority monitoring report we
obviously try to be really proactive in
mopping up any any other completion so
we try to be you know try to apply the
same scrutiny here but at the end of the
year I suppose it's not it's not
wonderful seeing that we might ring
around some of the developers to get you
know accurate figures formal basing
think our completions and then we
obviously have to do a little bit of
work internally to work out why that
might be different from what's being
recorded to us and that's really the way
in which we remembered that on project
nursery for example there were probably
40 homes being lived in at one point in
time and we don't even talk that ADEs of
those had been signed off by building
inspectors clearly I don't know the four
reasons why that was but you know that
is a bit of a problem I guess we're
relying on that on that source of
information and in terms of the other
ways of kind of monitoring completions I
mean we can use obviously council tax
capital tax so I knocked I suppose as an
alternative a measure of that there
tends to be I would say a slight delay
in the house being functionally complete
and it being registered for council tax
but it is if members would find it
useful and I'm more than happy to for
them for the next monitoring update to
to give some regards to council tax
registrations to see whether or not
there is you know an appreciable
difference between what's coming through
the building control records and counter
tax records and see whatever or not that
might provide a more accurate source of
information I think we've just
interrupts in here I think anything that
we give us a more accurate assessment
would be welcome so simple as that so if
you can do that today that's fine I
think really we I think there's some of
the difficulty with some of these very
large private sites is that the way that
they of
get there I was signed off by building
inspectors they they might do them in
bulk they might effectively have lots of
houses that are functionally completely
fit for people to live in but you know
the paperwork or whatever has not been
filed until a point in the future and
then so that it does make it slightly
difficult for us to be precise I suppose
because if we don't have that
information provided to us at point it's
on we're looking it does lead to that
delay that I mentioned of having to pick
up additional completions you know the
weeks and months that follow rather than
necessarily at the time carrier assembly
also will come to encounter but yeah I
just think that six months is excessive
especially properties especially if this
has been brought up not at this
committee but in the past where the
council is losing revenue because it's
not sure I understand the criteria so if
your later stage improving who who do
you need to to notify that to go well
duh I mean we have contacts in ocm
council tax Timbers you do smokers so we
can we can speak to them and understands
you know their process a little bit
better and hopefully we can give them an
appreciation of our process and if
obviously hopefully
an opportunity let's tie things up I
mean we have spoken to them extensively
in the past and I guess that's where
we've developed some of the
understanding that there might be delays
and where is that I may put the ball in
your court if you find that when we have
our next meeting if you find that this
isn't going according to plan then you
raise it with us we'll make sure it
doesn't go according to plan
um yeah I'm more than happy to give
conversations okay to do not signing it
off because they're way too pretentious
to come through six months or a year
later couple things to snag initiative
retention net that's one of the
questions I've been asked is the other
question is listen mace was talking
about people council tax Olli
if someone's moved in they would be made
would be solid Shimon council track
straight away so they could get a year
down the line people who've lived in the
house would've earn one of a year's bill
what can we do as a Christian tell me to
come it's any clause that we could put
in any of these building these new
building things that they're coming up
I'm not sure maybe in in in money to
answer this question because if we've
got clauses within a billion plan sure
they've got to keep to that particular
date and spell or whatever it is
to make sure these sort of yeah spoken
on the first point about how I guess you
kind of define when a house is
completely I suppose there's there isn't
that the two main ways clearly are you
know when they first registered in the
council tactics because it's obviously
they that team has a has a depth as a
different issue for what a completed
houses than they can also start charging
council house on the kind of definition
that we currently work so Lucas a is
more about when has a building inspector
gone round and signed off the building
as effectively you know compliant with
building regs in terms of ongoing
snagging issues what I would say and I'm
not a building inspector it might be
there you know I can kind of return with
a view from one of the counselors
Building Control offices but oh I
wouldn't be surprised if a lot of the
houses that have kind of smacking issues
etc probably having been signed off
mostly so they might have ongoing issues
I've always use that perhaps develop
after somebody has moved in but clearly
if there are situations where people are
moving into houses that haven't got
final sign-off from building inspectors
that's simply not an ideal situation for
us monitoring but I think probably it
would be a question I'd have to put to
the council only control team as to the
likelihood of that happening and then
how that might then effect our
monitoring if we I guess there are two
sides to it you know I've are we
recording completions we're actually
held is aren't fit for occupation yet
I'd like to think not but the other side
is are we not recording completion is in
a timely way we're actually the house is
ready for occupation so it might be
something if it's okay that I returned
to the subcommittee
from from the building control emphasis
on just because I guess there is a bit
of a divide between the planning process
and the building control process and as
you may know whereas planning is you
know the council has a responsibility to
plan you can't go to somebody else to
ask them for planning permission we're
building control and you can appoint
private suitably qualified building
inspectors who may have different
processes to the council some of them
are obviously fantastic and some of them
might be less good and you know it might
be that some of those less less good
ones are where we sell you something
those have some problems with in terms
of getting paperwork back in their time
away everything else in terms of your
point about putting things into I guess
planning permissions I mean the real
difficulty is and I mean there are
conditions always on plan permissions
about where the development has to have
started by and that normally is three
years but you know as much as I think a
lot of people have hope that you could
put something in there which really sets
the developer you know targets or or
something even stronger than that about
when they have to do have the complete
houses buy it it's not really an option
to my knowledge to really require them
to do that I mean it's conceivable that
you might get a developer to agree a
kind of legal agreement that that really
or if it was kind of a joint venture you
know they might agree to deliver a
certain number of houses at a certain
date XYZ but I don't think it's really a
power that councils can use to require
developers to complete to a certain
timetable it tends to be and it does
cause some problems
to be that once a developer started they
kind of have forever any day to complete
that site and I won't defend that
because I don't think it necessarily is
a good thing but it's I guess it's you
know it might be a little bit beyond the
counselors influence to to control that
was there anything that I didn't answer
no no thank you
some thank Jennifer interesting finish
where you it's a nightmare for you as I
said it sort of but everything is moving
and you know you talked about 2008 11 to
2018 the last six months projecting
forward and then of course you talk
about current year plan
I can see news sites have come on stream
but what these next figures were talking
about in the sense that at the same time
as we're focusing on new completions
there must be some of our housing stock
which is ceasing to be habitable for
whatever reason it disappears so I'm
just wondering where we sit you you talk
about the 20-year projection any
pre-ground terms mm we know where
they're coming from which leaves us
5550 a year director two three five big
one on the paper they mentioned 385 so
but it's trying to really get a real
staple where we are rather than I'm not
suggesting for one moment prove my
selling figures but making figures tell
the story we will to tell and I accept
is an absolute yeah the other thing is I
just wonder whether we are exploiting
all of our brownfield sites number of
brownfield sites with align its wonder
where there's an opportunity for what
chrysotile or perhaps suitable
paleontologist so they've got a
brownfield sites
to see what we can do to develop those
very very - so on your first point so
all the figures in terms of targets and
delivery are are always kind of
expressed as net so we do lose some
homes to demolition for example so it
might be you know if you knock down a
house and build three in its place you
know then then that it really contribute
to the house so the district's housing
supply in terms of houses becoming
uninhabitable I mean it's it's kind of
the reverse problem to their completions
monitoring really it's that you know
when when becomes a point where you can
kind of robustly say well that house is
no longer part of of the housing stock
of the district so you'd probably say
well if the house is just being you know
refurbished if it's being even if it's a
gun season being refurbished then
probably another point is that public
housing but they don't do come occasions
kind of from time to time where you have
to take every unit a house really is you
know there's different ways of looking
at it but you know abandon one kind of
planning language definition really
where a house really isn't fit for
occupation you know if it's got a huge
hole in its roof and probably time can't
count anymore but it is difficult to
monitor in the sense that nobody
necessarily tells you that they've
abandoned their their house so the only
way we would really ever have a finding
that out however if there happens to be
a planning application
to redevelop it was that point maybe it
becomes a little bit moved anyway
because if you're redeveloping it then
you you're gonna replace it or if that
house can be registered for council tax
purposes again that's a question
probably for my council tax colleagues
but you know if there comes a point
where you can no longer count a house as
being capable of you know collecting
council tax against then there's a good
case to say that you nobody should be
knocking that off on their tickets as a
loss to them the district's housing
stock but I must say it is quite rare to
my knowledge about didn't happen it's
probably more common that houses kind of
fall into a state of relative disrepair
but probably enough to just stop being
counted as a house so just pick table
that point it's negligible really what
you're suggesting is it's so they
naturally stop working against against I
guess you know that completions we see
on a site like all Road would you might
be push a hundred a year you know we're
probably talking about you know fewer
than 1000 on the brownfield sites I mean
generally speaking I mean there there is
a kind of presumption in favor of
redeveloping brownfield sites so in
terms of national policy in terms of
local policy I mean generally speaking
the site comes in that means policy in
that regard then then the presumption is
that it that it will be appropriately I
don't want to step too much
inter-community territory because
obviously every application has to come
perform Development Committee for
consent but no very matter before you
even consider a Greenbelt release and
other sources it kind of meets the
housing needs thing then you do have to
maximize where those brownfield sites
and I guess it's we publish a brown foot
register it's two for its annual update
kind of imminently so that is a kind of
list of no Braunfels
it's in the district that are believed
to be available suitable and broadly
liable for redevelopment and you know I
guess there's always a case to say maybe
we should be more proactive in how some
of those sites coming forward difficulty
always being that they tend to be in
private ownership and unless obviously
that the owner brings forward planning
application then you know to some extent
you know you can put it in as many
registers and policies and plans and
everything else as we want but we're not
always necessarily there the telly so I
guess in those in those senses so that
you yeah so there is a catalog you're
reasonably confident that they are
cataloged and we've got as near as we
can be sure the comprehensive mr. Felix
yeah I mean I mean I guess the crucial
thing is is are they available so there
are there are an enormous number of
sites there could we do more could we be
more proactive do we need to do
something to ensure that we are on top
of them making sure we are optimizing
the potential of those prototypes I
think I think there's there's definitely
a place to say that I guess what I'm
with what I would say is that you know
we so there's organizations out there
like Holmes England and other
organisations who you know we have
something of a kind of embryonic
dialogue we've who I think very much of
pushing the kind of brownfield
maximization agenda you know they may be
able to offer support in cases where
there are either land ownership issue so
maybe the landowner isn't willing to be
the site forward for whatever reason or
maybe where the costs of you know
remediating the land or whatever it
might be are make
non-viable you know that there is
support out there for stuff like that I
mean as a taking and obviously taken in
to the acceleration of see the economic
development team here I know you do work
with closely you know there is I'm sure
a desire to see more of those sites
developed but I guess it is it does come
down to that are they available and
there is always this kind of weighing up
exercise are supposed to be had because
quite often you know whether we're they
not necessarily arguments but let's say
arguments had is then in detail about
what's being proposed because you have
that kind of in principle presumption in
favor but then if what's being proposed
fails to be policy in enough in in other
ways then I guess that's often something
that Development Committee will have to
weigh up is is I obviously think you
know I you know I appreciate it
that's it's relatively embryonic as well
but you know the council has a role in
that for whose assets program as well
and other things like that you know
these are all these are all kind of
things that I guess people are pushing
forward
oh it could always be done yeah Mike
yeah just a couple things yeah money on
the point when traffic original thing
this casing allowed this month not that
so on the keen on the ground for bridges
yes I think that would be that plate
list and pay [ __ ] went on them on the
list that you've got plating things with
some roads that I know is a long list of
sight I have to confirm not wear any new
properties on the river side of the road
because that's potentially not just one
surprise and that's not this recent
routine deeply certainly going to prove
up up to about 2003 yeah I guess this is
others on the other page first there's
gonna be fourteen might potentially
gonna be
20 new homes on that cycle yeah I guess
it's so this is this is I guess logging
how many homes have been delivered in
that precise fix month window but but
this event might be coming back to be
honest I've certainly said more than one
delivered I think there's been holding
I'm loving whole brief certainly up
until September we must have seen it
around
well it comes down so I guess so I
suppose this I suppose there are two
things on that I guess is that firstly I
guess this does only cover until the
period of September 2019 so you know
it's very possible that there have been
while they will have definitely been
more delivered in the last three months
ideally I think we would have presented
you with a table covering until the end
of December 2019 I think this meeting
probably came slightly too soon as have
you ever seen to give you accurate
figures for that
I'm not saying about the saying that
they were up to September there at least
legally but there's not be many plug
issues that was all an illness becomes
go just yeah that's okay that saw it if
there is therefore and a space about
there's water it might come down so I
guess what we've what we've said it out
about some of the other about some of
the delay with with having that stuff so
it might be that they are functionally
complete but if the developer hasn't got
the building inspector around for final
sign-off or something you know something
like that then it might be that actually
we were 2019 and 15 were delivered but
actually from the tents purposes they
were so I guess it comes back to again
is what is our most accurate way of
measuring there but that was the second
there are three items I mean you said
what we we classes commenced what did it
all completed historian copies from its
earlier completed and what does the
government expect or don't they defined
completed it so they don't as far as I'm
aware have a standard way of defining
completed or commenced but they do
suggest that one or count
tax records and/or building control
records is the best way of monitor again
imagine now that up and down the country
probably different counselors use
different things so I suppose what I
what I think would probably be quite
useful is if I have a conversation with
the council tax team and try to work out
you know this is there a case to say the
council tax records are updated faster
and more accurately than building
intolerant towards then there's probably
a good case to say that's what we should
be using from now on or is it the case I
suppose that further control records are
updated faster than council tax records
so could we just use the earlier on so
you so inside you know you're up there
with control sign-off or council tax
yeah I'm sure we could and I'm not so we
my soul my fingers but it gives us if we
ain't pretty more even frozen most
sensible that's a good point I think I
think it's I'll not have to understand I
suppose from council tax how they do
their reporting but you know clearly
there there there there must be people
who are having to longer new sights new
houses I should say for council tax
purposes so it's it's just about I
suppose having your timely access to
that resource and then I think that I
think if the solution as we said earlier
this mindset do if you need us to get
involved there is an easy solution to
come up with this you tell us and we'll
couch I'll get involved high level it
was don't don't like so I think I did
everybody giving each the council I say
oh I must have a king's house if you
bring an empty home because I care for
many homes pay council tax anyway don't
they stop as you guys listen I think I
think it comes down to a little bit
about that code that thing about all
they are banner and there are they just
empty an empty house is still part of
the council's housing stock but an
abandoned home isn't and I guess it's
it's a dilemma for us to have I dare say
they probably are a good number of empty
homes in the district
one time but there are
yes so I playoff for all you're talking
about the same side so it is the West
Raley allocation I mean the 550 makes
provision for so there was the Grange
bullets development as well so I think
that's an amalgamation but I take the
point we we've been inconsistent with
the Sun referencing they I think the way
to planning applications are enormous is
normally land sale for a plane and north
of London Road which may be a little bit
more helpful for understanding where I
guess so in terms of is so I think what
we're trying to say on five point four
is very reality so they cut the country
so I know what was always referred to as
to come so that means the large and we
have information suggests that 54 than
those 500 have had a technical
commencement now what that might mean is
just a bit
foundations yes whereas I guess the but
I think probably they have a different
test action plan probably the entire
site laid within the entire allocation
which might include range builders as
well so but up but in terms of being
consistent concise records don't you
learn something that we can do it is
there anything specific about say we so
taking apart the trajectory that was
that prayer time cool strategy so that
was the 2011 trajectory I think as we
all know that a lot of those types
didn't come always as fast as we with
expected so really post 20 to 21 is now
going to be see five more delivered bang
was he visited the core strategy mostly
to make up the shortfall against the
early delivery that that never quite
happened so Table six is I suppose the
accurate as of accurate as of today
equal most
cans for that specific site we're
estimating that 80 homes will be
delivered before I I would have to look
at the background spreadsheet to clarify
exactly what countries this I think
probably doesn't use them to grow
because I don't think the legal
agreement has been signed so I think
this is more the larger size plus Grange
villains because both of those have at
least outlined we should I think that
the large site probably going to come
through as a series of reserved matters
rather than one and I think that's
probably in the other science I think
timber grows probably and a faculty
within that six hundred sixty so the
other sites includes and other
permissions Bradford allocations with
Winkle sites
I probably should also say sites with
resolutions graph transformation
accepting see the growth has been sparse
understand see Development Committee I
think the outstanding issues the
Green yeah so I think I think so timber
groves the only one I know of them that
is pending illegal agreements the other
sites are the so the other sites listed
are the allocations from the allocations
plan and it's obviously the core
strategy the vast majority of them have
the one that obviously doesn't southeast
dashing didn't which I think would come
before the relevant committee vision
this year and the vast majority of them
actually have either full and Commission
or outline and reserved matters the only
ones that I'm aware of that don't are I
think the site in little west of little
Wakering Road I think that may not have
reserved matters yeah and part on the
west side that's reserved matters I
think the remainders subject occasions
anybody else right I've got a few
questions you know I'm here
this is there anything we can do to
ensure that private building inspectors
suppliers with their comment permanently
promptly urgently so what I would say is
that most of them are pretty good and so
we get a monthly return from the nhbc
which covers the majority of sites the
only one that I am aware of that we had
fundamental issues with was Pancho's
nursery
so that's the only large site that I'm
aware of that had significant problems
with their returns I think it's
definitely conversation I can have with
builder control manager to see whether
or not me you've received there to be
any new thing we can do I think it's
it's difficult because it might be the
like I say they might be completing the
house it's been not getting final
sign-off and I don't there's probably
not on that we can do to compel them to
get the houses signed off wake up
perhaps there's something we can do to
get them it's a report it's quicker so I
guess we might be able to solve
okay number two you'll hear your
projection of two hundred and twelve
houses against the 380 fiber we should
have leaves a shortfall as I see abound
in 73 so and you said that in your
professional opinion at the moment you
know okay
well at what point is that okay at what
point do we say we've got a problem our
action plan isn't
dragna's to where we should be and that
this situation potentially won't be
getting better
that figures won't be improving they'll
just be understand where they are or
arguably getting worse at what point is
that when when do we when do you say
we've got to start taking a different
form of action to our plan that we
currently have him in place so I suppose
what I would say is that there's there's
no not necessarily any penalty for
failing so because if you build enough
houses in any given year so I suppose
that's one reason why I'm saying it's
not necessarily a matter for immediate
concern you know there may be a
shortfall I guess there are two main
ways in which you're performing assisted
these monitors your housing delivery
performance monitored
one of those is their housing delivery
test
which is kind of looking back over the
past three years and if you have an over
that three-year period average now
delivered enough houses then you may
have to put together an action plan if
it's really bad then you may the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development would apply it's still not
very clear how that affects creamed of
districts I'm not aware today of any
appeals where the inspector is taking
the view that in housing delivery is
more important than Greenville Casa
Point famously won their case Joplin's
farm where they had very low housing
five years supply and and yet the
inspectors still the back the green belt
over it so I suppose and sorry the other
way that housing housing completions are
kind of measured is in terms of
maintaining a five year supply of houses
so that's looking too forward into the
future are you going to be up enough
powers over the next five years to meet
targets so the reason why I say is not
necessarily immediately concerned in
looking forward is that we have got all
of those two sites now churn well will
begin to churn our houses so we've got
whole bridge we've got West Raley we've
got the remainder of all Road we've got
remainder of great Wakering and
depending the decision development
committee we're likely to have southeast
Ashington and together those houses we
estimate are enough to maintain our five
year supply or more near enough clearly
I think I've said this before you know
if we are in a position in saying two or
three years time where we have an
identified further sources of housing so
to pick up where those sites will leave
up then we could face a situation where
we struggle to demonstrate that you know
we're going to build enough house
I mean the main way in which you would
normally remedy that the concern is
obviously by introducing a new local
implant which might identify further
sources of housing and the idea would be
to pick up where though where your last
plan left off and hopefully maintain
that five year supply of housing it's
still not 100% clearing I suppose what
the risks are to the council of failing
to maintain that five year supply of
housing because like I say me it's not
as though there are lots and lots of
districts around the country a Greenbelt
district articulately you are losing
Appeals for housing in the green but
clearly it's not necessarily a good or
healthy place to be in turn you know
very happens if a local plan with
inadequate supply of housing so whilst
the risks might be low clearly it's you
know it's something that all councillors
are expected to aspire seriously and
whilst their one measure of being
up-to-date bodies having a five year
supply of housing which we just about do
you know you know I cannot have
certainty that that would still be the
case in two or three years time if we
haven't got a local planner through by
then and I think that's that's the
difficulty really is you know clearly
we're still very much working on
producing a local plan with that we hope
very much will be in place until all
three years the hybrid but you know it's
right and proper that the subcommittee
monitor of performance against that and
obviously I do my best to articulate
what the risks are but some do you want
to come back yeah I mean that's all it
sounds to me as if first of all you
contained a defensive position you know
in the light of or we know we're not
meeting the targeted figures and you
know the facts are the facts you know
you can say you know big environment
lack of the week and what if that face
has to me is if we were to be
being responsible thinking about a new
development plan the first one the
second point is we think of him were
looking quite rightly we're looking at
arrow but the spotlight is likely to be
shone on us if we are fading in relation
to other authorities around us and we
are significantly different although at
target they're doing better
so what monitoring do we keep more
people going on around us to see whether
or not they're getting the same issues
but certainly trying out because I think
if we constantly adopt a defensive
position to three years time it's gonna
be too late then it was very huge catch
up it seems to be a responsible position
for the authority to be to constantly
review update and renew tear up the old
one other code size so the positioning
for challenge so I suppose the points to
make on that really I guess is that as a
council we are really working on the
total I suppose so
on the local plan itself you know
clearly it's a while ago now when we'd
go out on issues and options on that and
there's been in quality got lots of
technical evidence whether it's been
done with since then and obviously we
hope to go out consultation on the next
round really probably in the summer
that's something that's got to come
through this subcommittee it is it isn't
hasn't progressed as fast as our adopted
timetable envisage I think that's fair
to say
and there's a number of reasons for that
you know one of one of which is probably
the changing kind of landscape in which
we are trying to plan you know we
national policy been changed twice in so
years of staying the same for six so
it's you know they've been kind of new
requirements that have to be taken into
account and I suppose the other aspect
of it really is the other kind of
development plan that we are working
towards which is the kind of South Essex
level stuff which is still in relative
early stages but again has been a lot of
technical evidence it's been worked on
on that and I guess the aspiration
remains that we all have that as a
strategic and then there will be you
know six level plans underneath it from
each of those constituent authorities
which are their kind of local strategies
with the key big picture issues being
dealt with in the south physics stuff so
very much we do work with on even a
foreign keys so we were one of the
authorities who receives letters from
the Secretary of State so battling for
everything cause for point receive
letters because their plans were
approaching 20 years of age ours is you
know not coming up to nine years old
which is you know quite quite old
they're not quite that old and I suppose
it's you know it's it is a risk in the
background is that you know if you don't
progress a development plan in a timely
way then you know there is always a risk
that you know a Secretary of State or a
new Secretary of State or or Secretary
of State's from now you know might
decide that you know Robster doesn't you
know there could be a number of
appointees you know we're not happy and
it cost a point as an enrichment you
know will testify that they haven't
received a letter like that
they've now had to really try and
accelerate through their plans and most
of them are now kind of at the stage
where they're toying with submission so
there is we have you know recently but
we are in the process of responding to
pass the points that they plan final
local plan which I think she should be
with members now possible so we but what
I would say it really is that I guess I
come up to that point about where we're
at right now
the reasons are relatively low but
clearly we are trying to progress a
development plan as quickly and as
effectively as possible having regard to
the failures of many many development
plans nationally at the moment for an
enormous number of reasons and it does
seem very difficult landscape we've been
which to get a local plan examined and
doctors so we're having to us they take
take lessons from all of those but
clearly if in two and for two or three
years time you know we we are you know
not looking at a local plan you know
either ready to examine or or had been
examined then you know the risks may
well be greater I guess it's you know
it's worth being aware of those risks
although they're they are necessarily
about that amazingly clear right now
you know what those might be the
September you're now saying possibly
some that's a year late there's not just
the implication of problems processing
council the
the other problem is that when we go out
we had a tremendous high level of
engaging the community where originally
but it's soda box but on this contract
there are public that's going to wonder
what we've been doing in in that time
and also you've mentioned that the it's
nine years old let's not bring out that
we were told as a council that we have
to have an early revision and I don't
consider ten years and early revision
but so is there anything that can be
done to speed this process up you think
that it would appear that it's slipping
and slipping and slipping and so many no
I totally understand that and and I
guess you know when when we put those
time to a previous timetable its members
you know they were we've you know
confidence good faith that that's a
timetable that we
me I guess it's you know it's been
challenging I think in terms of the
relationship with the South Wessex plan
in terms of getting evidence in place to
be able to to justify a kind of
preferred strategy and those changes to
national policy
I think it's been challenging to really
make substantial progress on that at the
time that we very liked I think what
would you know what would definitely
need to have to be now is I think
probably the next meeting of the
planning policy subcommittee it will
almost certainly involve like a seminar
kind of internal thinking is that the
next stage in probably late spring early
summer is realistic to allow us to get
the rest of that evidence in place but
also to to give members good time to
consider that and report it obviously
have to come to a subcommittee and
property council so you know I mean it's
in terms of how it can be accelerated I
mean it's you know we we are having a
conversation house you know there there
there are kind of some structural
changes to planning going on the moment
that you know may mean that we can
better focus on addressing the local
plan that maybe we have been able to
that's not an unfair statement and you
know I have relative confidence that
where we're now we're in terms of
evidence and and program and everything
else that they should not be a snitch
this time against summer and summer
dates but there is still work to be done
that's very difficult to say how it can
be accelerated you know you could put an
enormous number of people onto it but
actually not you know in my experience
not actually the best resource councils
aren't always the ones that progress the
local plans quickest you know so it's
it's it is challenging and I appreciate
having properly answered your question
there but is can I just come back in
here with one thing before we move on
you know we're asking you to produce
more and more information to to better
figures one thing another and things are
slipping so I've got you know the
obvious room question that you've have
touched on is resources and and do we
have the resources to meet all these
requirements that we are asking you to
meet the central government for council
everybody is asking you to meet now as
far as I say this this is the two of you
now I know we've been down this road
before we got sold off last time so we
get told off again but and I understand
you saying that you know we'll just keep
throwing more and more people in but it
it is to my mind an issue that we have
got to address and if we are demanding
and requesting more and more information
from you then we got to make sure we've
got the resources in place to supply
this information I don't think it's
rocket science so we move on but I don't
expect you to answer that down on just
OPP I mean it's easy I know now coming
to you Carol yeah I've gone
[Music]
within us either the original timetable
was unrealistic or there's a problem
that it needs to be addressed and it
would appear to me that the only
addressing that's going on is the
changing dates which is not not your
call because it's not really the
acceptable situation unless we really
sit down sit down
you say to us this is what I need to do
what you can also asking you to do we're
not going to go any further we're going
to come back to this same situation and
I think through your chair we have to
need to have a meeting on this when in
advance much much sooner than that in
the summer or the spring of whatever it
is we're not getting anywhere religio
not get anywhere and I've got great
concerns too with with us relying on the
building the builders signing things off
we've got to be much more stronger
somewhere than the hair we're gonna do
what legal emphases we got to do but we
are literally just you know back camera
going round and round in circles and we
are wasting our time I know I think
we've all come to the same conclusion
como I think I hope councillor waters
the portfolio that the planning is
taking on board
concerns and will be chilly passing
those up the line I think if we need to
make any further representation on
behalf of this committee to fall Council
we will do so I'm not quite sure how we
can do it but I think we will and we
need to because there's a so I think
we've all highlighted a lot of concerns
about things there being not meeting
targets not be in numbers I'll get Sonya
to give me some guidance perhaps outside
this meeting how we can progress this
with that with the people that need to
be made aware of it and I think you know
I mean I've in accordance with our
earlier request from last year's made
our last times meeting I think the next
meeting is going to be programmed for
April between now and then we need to
have something in place other than as as
our suggested just coming back an
earring well we're sliding and we're not
meeting targets and then we got come on
yes
we're all great that is the problem of
slippage and it's also on the earlier
point there's the problem problem that
joint out thank you and I know that the
last waiting we six three monthly
meetings but in viewers we're also the
same things each time perhaps something
that you think constructive I think if I
may if if we say that April which will
give a portfolio older and then time to
come back but if in your opinion there
is something worthwhile talking about
before there then we'll arrange an
earlier meeting but I don't want to come
back in February and say well actually
we're not we haven't got too far enough
down the road to proposing but I police
the backstop if we can't if we can do
anything earlier then we'll uh we'll
have it might be yeah quickly yeah just
on this point nothing else just on this
one point oh I just need to clarify that
something that was raised just probably
going up with regard to ground phone we
just needed a clarification with regards
to as we're bringing forward any
brownfield sites just to clarify would
they be classed as willful and so any
annotations we have we will still have
to do
that was that was just walked in a clary
occasion or is committed yeah basically
on that and also as far as the comments
that have come forward yeah we're gonna
I'm having portfolio over meeting next
week all these points where their works
are being attendants we can then put all
these points to assistant director and
to make sure that they all go forward
you know as far as askance thank you but
I will get a result
April is the little dogies my back stuff
but if we look the first something
sooner if we if we have something
concrete I plan of action the we that
reflects the concerns of this committee
that we can bring forward earlier okay
okay members anybody got anything else
okay anything else might you okay yeah
okay well members if there's nothing
else to to raise we have one resolution
on here I recommend Isis it is proposed
that the subcommittee resolves that the
housing delivery update report April 20
19 September 2019 1502 sorry yeah okay
that's fine so every house built in the
district regardless of the weather is
for you Phil brownfield in the plan
knowing the plan counts towards the
monitoring that we do
council was the government assessment of
our performance so windfall I guess
really just means that it's not in the
plan
I was not identified at the time of the
plan being produced and obviously now
that we say ten years there is quite a
lot of the smaller sites were identified
over time to plan being put together
there's now been ten nine years so and
it was agreed that a certain amount of
the wind web sites could be incorporated
because of the fact that we can prove
that we have so many over a period of
time so presumably that should actually
be in their figures so I say yes so the
windfall allowance is something that you
can so basically you can put in an
unspecified windfall allowance when
you're working out your housing numbers
on the basis that you can prove that
over the last five ten years you've
consistently had you know sites in the
urban area whatever it might be
come available for development and
they've always made a contribution so
these are by their very nature is not
sites that you know about yet so you
could just make them available so that's
still very much amazing case I think
that said at the last subcommittee
though probably in the region of 30 or
40 weddings per year we could probably
just define cluding in our trajectory
but obviously sites that we know about
now are windfall but they would still
count and so if you were to put together
a bit almost like a schedule of all
science so then all the ones you know
about however many they will deliver at
each year and then you have
the bottom row would be windfall
allowance which is you know let's say 30
per green and that all totter together
gives you your overall supply and that's
what when we take a new local plan to
examination you know that schedule will
be the basis for the inspector
determining whether or not we should in
terms of five year supply so 5b housing
supply looking forward I think a lot of
councils we don't need to date but I
take the point on consider it in maybe
years four and five I think of you being
that you if you don't know about the
site yes then it's unlikely to to
deliver in the next one to three years
in terms of the retrospective housing
delivery test obviously the waiting for
site you've know about all the house I
think when we do five years supply
analysis in the future we can definitely
look at incorporating I would have
filled out I think it's a lot of last
question with you
chair shot was an intention of I didn't
really get out of school and maybe
outside this meeting you know you're
able to come back to us on other
authorities so we get a feel of where we
sit in relation to other authorities but
certainly from what I'm hearing from
your summing up comments and all those
who came to get to the the bottom line
of this report but it really is quite
worrying anything to know or might come
up no implied criticism of officers here
but this is real concerns and I'm sure
outside this meeting there's got to be
some work done in terms of perhaps
across party would
this is something that affects like all
of the districts I think that I think
that's outside this agenda at the moment
but I just really yeah you know we've
touched on our concerns into Buffalo
Creek there's a whole load of things and
I think what you're keying to do chair
if I understand is to switch it from a
reactive where we're just noting things
they're very weak it is really a very
weak coming we're noting something so
what I think will to be stronger than
that we want to do more than noting it
we want to is stronger member
involvement to support and then help
officers come up with a solution on
these things yeah that's better member
engagement thank you thank you well as
we got in front of us at the moment is
recommendation resolves at the housing
very update before April 20 1920
September September 29 be noted I think
happy to know that but I think we've got
enough issues and I know that we'll
close the meeting up 15:08
if we may and I think